[ __ ] man I'm tired yeah me too I haven't
slept a whole lot in Pasco today
no it's has been horrible whoa phone
dude silence is golden these people
don't realize I'm about to film who's a
sumbitch from tinder Oh [ __ ] hos all
up on my dick hey guys I'm Ryan right
and I'm Jerry we're gonna watch the
street but yeah yeah when we have what
know that we got the green screen now
we're reviewing a movie yes spoiler
review spoilers reasons to see of
guardians of garden gardeners of the
gallic star dinner's at the galaxy stay
tuned okay
so small independent flick came out
guardians of the galaxy yeah like a
hundred thousand dollar movie maybe if
ya micro budget yeah no money and it
looks pretty good for her such a slim
low budget yeah that's like wow that's
impressive yeah a lot of your friends to
help but it's this movie to me is one of
the most entertaining movies I've seen
all year yeah this is a lot of fun the
only movie that competes with
entertaining for me is the lego movie
which also soars Chris Pratt
I wouldn't put them on the same double
feature but yeah they're both very
entertaining the entertaining as heck
from beginning to end this film just
works yeah man
because one of the genres to me a lot of
critics have been saying and like when I
walked out I was like yeah I feel this
way I was one of those movies that made
sure not to read any reviews before I
saw it to me it's like this is the first
Marvel movie where I would say like
comedy is probably one of the John Rah's
oh yeah you know this movie is
definitely this movie definitely has a
very strong sense of quirkiness and
comedy intrinsically
like oh throughout it's not just like oh
well lighten the mood here and there
it's like they take time to bring humor
into the story like Iron Man 3 was
walking that line of funny movie to
comedy a little bit and then but this
one is like no they this is a real like
Marvel comedy we got going on it yeah
exactly well because these characters
are from all different places and so
there's just
natural kind of comedy that comes from
watching them try to interact with each
other
and they're so committed to the
characters to the detail of like their
interaction and who would feel this way
towards one another and why there would
be friction here was just I was so well
thought out well yeah and it almost has
that Avengers theory of like these
people should not be in the same room
together and I don't know how they're
gonna work together but that's the fun
of the movie is watching how they do
overcome their difference yeah
like the Avengers is really funny as
well like that's like this movies just a
blast like well it's just an
entertaining sci-fi action avenger man
well I'm glad you since I because like
I'm really happy to see Marvel doing
something like this because you know
it's we've done so many superhero movies
where the conflict is like lab explosion
happened and now I'm a Lea nated from
society and people don't like vigilante
justice these people are all kind of
traumatized by different things but
they're not particularly super they all
have skills and things that make them
special but it's not like a superhero
movie it's more of a sci-fi multiple
alien species and different worlds you
know it's yes aliens shooting up New
York yeah which is which is always a
plus to not do that well James Gunn and
and and I was about to say to Josh
Brolin that would be Joss Whedon you can
see where I got ya
they both have a very inherent sense of
comedy too or you know Yammer to their
to their work and I thought James Gunn
was like the perfect choice for this oh
absolutely you know it he cast it so
well
mmm like everyone's great in it you know
like this is spoiler review so we'll
talk about all that everyone die
everyone die every loose Willis the
whole time it was the night it was a
modern day but we thought it was the
1900s and they're really aliens like
from the very beginning to setting up
these characters like this is a very
character-driven movie the prologue you
know it's this poopy it's like so funny
but the prologue is so serious tear it
up man I was like no I am so sad I was
like this isn't doesn't seem like the
fun movie every daughters telling me
about this is really emotional yeah it's
got some heart you know yeah the mom's
dying and she kind of looks like an
alien at first you know like she has
some kind of terminal illness I know but
it looked kind of
really the fact the ones when they first
opened up on her I was like wow she
looks really sickly really I thought she
kind of looked like the splice creature
I don't know what she had it seemed like
some kind of cancer it's like you know
when your hair goes away and you're like
really skinny and emaciated your head
gets that sort of alien thing probably
just out of cold yeah it's a really bad
cold shitty cold if you suck her you
know she took her antibiotics she would
be [ __ ] health care at America and
that's not a real character but it's
still like that oh yeah and that one
scene you see that Chris Pratt is this
guy who like didn't even get to do his
mom's last request which was just a hole
his hat hold her hand which is so
heartbreaking in that moment well yeah
there's so much for a little kid did I
know Ross so much drama it's like
because I love that moment it's like
that is scary as a kid it's like you
know take my hand but you would be like
as a young child you are kind of scared
of those things just as much as you are
you know affectionate for your for a
parent so that's the handle that moment
really really gorgeous list yeah I was
it wasn't what I was expecting
no is it most maybe see with Charlie's
you just grab the hand yeah you know
it's little details like that make this
movie so moving detail [ __ ] details
deets oh yeah then he gets abducted and
which is like that kid just had the
worst David yeah I mean I understand
they got to do it that way and that's
probably of the comic it's like a
fateful day when my mom got abducted by
Michael Rooker that lays down the seed
for a common thread through the whole
movies like the music like it always
comes back to that little Walkman with
the with the awesome mix vol 1 or
something like that and like the music
is a character and there's so much
lively music in this movie and I need to
put that right in the DNA from the very
beginning when I saw the trailer I was
wondering like how is this music gonna
tie in with this movie exactly yeah I
was like is it just gonna set an ironic
tone where it's like oh it's badass but
it's like really light-hearted music but
it's more than that like it's it
actually is a part of the story and I
love the opening with Chris Pratt
himself where he breaks in he's like a
badass and then suddenly the movie just
not a movie just becomes the what it is
yeah just starts dancing and kicking
aliens around and [ __ ] it was so funny
they want to say guardians of the galaxy
it was hilarious yeah I really I really
loved it man poking fun at badassness
like every time there's a bad asthma and
it pokes fun at bad ass moments you know
and that was a great moment like they
they really know they just knew how to
set up these characters like from the
trailers I thought Peter quill is gonna
be kind of an idiot yeah well I didn't
get the sense he would mean any I get
the sense he was you know sort of a semi
[ __ ] up be sarcastic guy I don't know
whatever like in the movie he's not an
idiot I don't know like he knows what
he's doing he just is like Jurassic and
[ __ ] like he's he's not like a shitty
like space thief but he's just not I
don't know particularly outstanding at
it so he's always sort of like was one
of those guys who like if he focuses
he's the best yeah yeah he does have
some legit town it's not like one of
those movies where it's like you have no
talent he knows what he's doing it's
just you know he's a low-level thief guy
Chris Pratt is just amazing in this film
yes he is he a [ __ ] [ __ ] he got both
even bumpers covered in that orange yeah
he is peeling tomato juice looks like
they got sprayed by a skunk will really
on spaghetti sauce the sequence where
they all finally sort of do they all
meet each other finally yeah the whole
that whole fight in the city it
establishes everyone's specialties like
up front yeah in a clever way
you know and it's one of the best ways
to establish like why these guys don't
like each other make sense how they came
together well yeah there's like a really
cool trade of power in that scene
because and going back to the point
about about star-lord in general is like
he does kind of hold his own in that
fight it's not good at Hannegan so you
see everyone's strengths and weaknesses
as they're fighting
yeah like Gamora Gamora yakamora
is like expert martial artist yeah Chris
Pratt's good with his weapons and [ __ ]
and 'try and like rocker
rocky raccoon is Lula's character and
forever what I can love him dude and I'm
so happy because that was one of those
things where I was like
I don't know how they're gonna do this
and they'd far they did it like he looks
good I think I'd have all roles with
this will boom Bradley Cooper the most
yeah I guess he's he's a scene stealer
man
yeah I'm just [ __ ] amazing in this
film Chris Tuchman said it the best I
think I watch her - earlier today people
thought he could have been to Jar Jar
being Star Wars but he needed becoming
the Heath Ledger of the Dark Knight oh
yeah that's why he is worried yes she's
stupid the villain himself to me Ronin
didn't really care too much about him
yeah I liked his performance I really
liked Lee pace I thought he was really
cool I love their design it's almost the
same thing
I think Marvel has is developing a kind
of a problem with this is like they're
really good with their protagonists but
it's really hard to make the villains
really stand up really scare it like
it's hard to be like oh oh this guy like
you know I hate to go with the obvious
choices but it's like Bane or the Joker
or even the Scarecrow in you know Batman
Begins like those are all like oh god
like these guys could really do some
damage and there isn't any point in this
movie work or for me anyway where I was
ever really like oh this guy can triumph
like yeah that's my point is like and I
never felt that concern but I don't
believe that's the performers fault at
all or anything like that no yeah I
don't even think it's a fault really
it's just cuz the movies so fun well
that's the thing is for this movie I'm I
don't mind as much because it's you know
it's it's the tone and everything makes
it okay
I really like the performance I like the
way they portrayed him I liked the way
he looked at everything and I thought
he's an effective villain just in terms
of them having to play off each other
yeah it's just you know the jeopardy
isn't Marvel's got some issues
establishing Jeopardy's he's like yeah
just amongst the villains like they're
really good with hanging out with them
protagonists they're really good with
hanging out them you know like Marvel
got it right with Loki and the Avengers
well that was the one vilmer it was like
really Loki's gonna be and then and then
they saw and they were like oh yeah this
guy you know but in this film it's like
it's such a hanging out with it heroes
type of film that's the best stuff yeah
I mean it there's like you know they're
gonna win and it seems like the film was
sort of aware of that yeah so like
there's a lot of moments in it where
would be like kind of serious like
people would start talking to
and then we get a little expositional
and kind of monologue ii and then like a
joke would come in 30 seconds later it
seemed like it was aware yeah it's kind
of making fun in a way tongue-in-cheek
humor with it oh yeah it's like every
time it gets to movie ish some character
says something to deflate that moment
until these college idea the fact that
like we know like we're all gonna stand
up and get inspired together you know
that whole Rocket Raccoon thing of like
you got understanding alright we're all
sitting in a circle now like that's
really intended I was like yeah movies
dude or like when Chris Pratt was gonna
kiss ya more alike it was like this is
kind of cheesy and silly and I'm like
it's her into something really funny
yeah exactly what's a knife obvious yeah
yeah not just a space
feeling soon but even before that like
the the prison sequence was really fun
to watch too you ever have more fun
timing out of prison before the best
thing I despite like the great [ __ ]
action in the prison scene like it's
[ __ ] hilarious when they were coming
up with the planning routes just growing
and well yeah it's like they really knew
how to use all five of these people to
create little surprises or to kind of
mess with the action and I really
appreciate the way they sort of distinct
the distinctly draw these guys because I
noticed that scene it's like group just
goes off and it takes one nugget of
information because he would and he
wants to be helpful so he steals the
battery and then it's all it screws up
the plan I gotta say Vin Diesel white
really did a wonders on this character
yeah cuz he's he's a guy who says three
words well he says a fourth word
eventually but he says three kids FF and
fifth yeah what's the fifth one we are
Groot oh yeah not just I am but yeah
that's all he says throughout like the
whole movie but there was so much
personality to the guy well the we saw
actually the where I saw the movie they
played it like a featurette slash
interview thing afterwards and I
actually showed him in the studio and
James Gunn said like he could have just
come in and Hollywood at it and just be
like oh yeah I'm gonna say it like five
times and you do it apparently he did
like every Groot line like many times
that's different yeah they showed a
bunch of different takes and stuff so he
really got into this no yeah I imagine
you would crew was so cool that one
seemed like towards the finale or he
likes six zanthor like say six guys it
is wagging the Myrtle's a Hulk like when
when the hall picks of Loki it's like I
flash back to that mole house like
groups just [ __ ] kicking ass
perimeter here he just turns around
smiles I know it's so [ __ ] funny oh
good natured and I like that they use
him to to bring just some actual
beautiful moments into you know because
he's a plant and he's in touch with
nature and then they use it to pause
every now and again to be like oh this
is actually kind of beautiful like yeah
I'm just a neat thing to do you know
Rocket Raccoon and Groot were like yeah
the pairing of them was genius like I
know they got from the comics but like
the chemistry in this movie like when
GRU passes away
[ __ ] Rocky right yet everyone felt so
sad
it's like best friend Nina everyone felt
sad in the theaters you let him cry even
in that moment like Batista petting or
spitting it's kind of funny
better funny but it's also really sweet
yeah well that's the thing is like this
movie in these types of scenes and all
over the place it takes time to do
things that it doesn't have to do mm-hmm
and that's that's just I I'm happy about
that
I think they handled that really well
with the writing you just really trust
Groot
yeah you do he's like a best friend he's
like a best buddy you wish it was real
what and of everybody he's the most
good-natured in the most genuine of all
these guys it seems like yeah yeah he's
the gentle he just tags along who sees
the good in people
yeah [ __ ] love group but in the
prison in the prison fight that was
pretty [ __ ] cool my favorite part of
the whole prison fight was sabe are you
is it the little leg yeah I wasn't
expecting anything but it's Chris Pratt
Satan to dig so how's relaxed cuts in
between all the edges he is talking to
the gun just to deflate the momentum of
like everyone's doing the best thing
he's just trying to get this guy to give
him this prosthetic leg
and I think it's something that he
spends a lot of money on it's like he
gives the guy money it's so funny that
he's just doing that yeah they get
somebody and rocket was just [ __ ] with
it yeah it was hilarious to you riding
it
and the antigravity moment was pretty
[ __ ] like when they come together in
that moment like you see what's it Drex
drag accent well you see dress like oh
this guy's a badass fighter yeah
speaking dracs like just he was funny
like the fact that he hates us I was
surprised he surprised me he was really
good yeah one and that's again I'm gonna
save this a lot today it's like that's
another thing I really liked about this
movie is that they again they
distinctive I their characters and they
thought about where would these people
be from what's their culture like and
there is so much about the differences
between culture so I just really
appreciated that he comes from a place
where they are very literate and they
take things very literally so he doesn't
understand sarcasm or metaphor and so
much comedy comes out of that yeah yeah
and the guy played it to illustrate
nothing goes over man I'm catch to like
that very much
that keeps the characters from being
cliche to is like they're all really
distinct they all have these
personalities and like what just rocket
surprises you the most like he might be
the smartest one in the group you know
yeah like he's these are technical he's
shrewd but he's technical and they have
that one great emotional moment where
he's like losing it at the drive when
he's drunk yeah like those and he's like
crying and [ __ ] like that was pretty
emotional everyone in the theater
started going oh oh yeah they give you
these little nugge that whole thing of
like I didn't ask to be you know torte
harvested and torn apart and rebuilt
over and over again
oh damn like and that was when it
started to open up like all these people
have your kind of broken yeah like Bane
again is [ __ ] Bane the supporting cast
in general man yeah like a lot of people
they got a lot of good people I got gem
on Honsou and Glenn Close for like two
seconds and Michael Rooker he's like
there's a lot James Gunn regulars in
this movie yeah like Michael Rooker is a
man like I got just so natural he's
already like creepy and then he's in
this looking creepy inflamed aggrieved
it's like oh yeah the Olsen the most
natural performance I've ever seen like
the least amount of time I'd have to
take to get used to a guy who's blue and
has some kind of a
Mohawk yeah this is like yeah I could
see this is my Gege me doesn't seem that
threatening it's just at one [ __ ]
arrow that responds to him yeah it's
strange is like like it seems like Pratt
could take him out if it weren't for
that [ __ ] air oh you know yeah but
the guy history man yeah that's true
again we [ __ ] abducted him though why
but Michael Rooker has that like effort
like he's intimidating without having to
be intimidating yeah I just has a load I
get that yeah he's got that crazy eye
where you're like you could be really
cool or you could be really scared
there's one scene that I really did
enjoy a lot which was one I mean it kind
of didn't make sense oh now it does ah
just figure it out when he goes into
space because there's that awesome
[ __ ] fight sequence where after
Batista calls and Ronin and I'm like
that they're the pawns and [ __ ] that was
so [ __ ] cool then de Moura is out in
space dying yeah Chris Pratt's like let
me put on my salt snake helmet let's go
save her but at first I was like you'd
be dead but then they explained later
that he's not full human yeah I was like
don't you freeze I knew Vic when URI we
was freezing yeah he's starting to
freeze but he wasn't like just yeah like
what would really happen to a human
exactly how clever is that yeah is that
first you like mistake well yeah and
then I would want to go back and
re-watch it again to see if I can maybe
snatch a couple more of those details in
real time so I can feel better about it
cuz like when I saw the first time I was
like wait a minute I missed a reason of
why you won't be dead oh yeah and then
in the finale when he's like when our
road is like who are you guys he's like
you just said it were the guardians of
the galaxy [ __ ] I was like cool line
kind of a cop out though did not explain
why well yeah like wait a minute you're
not just it's you didn't defeat him just
because you happen to be this thing that
you only discovered you were right now
but then they explained explain it yeah
yeah I'm like okay good right okay they
covered it you got it you guys got it
well I gotta give them props because
this is Marvel's uh first female writing
credit oh really
yeah Nicole Perlman did we vote and a
lot of
I think that came along with suffrage
laying basic women's rights I mean it's
hard especially in sci-fi it like it's
sci-fi and action like there aren't a
lot of women who are welcomed into
writing these things and I guess Marvel
after she had sort of been pushed around
by like oh why should you romantic
comedy over here like I guess Marvel was
like here's a list of titles if you want
to write one write us up one she was
like I want guardians and they were like
you really get the sense that this is a
vast universe well a lot of stuff in it
and it's cool to see like these
different alien species who are
fascinated by a dog in a space station
you know it's like it's like there's a
weird essence of this like
cross-cultural thing about this movie
that I just thought was really cool it
could have possibly opened the door for
many other Marvel movies I hope that's
why I hope this is successful because I
would like to see them a keep making
confident choices with directors and
writers but also doing more like strange
left-of-centre material from their
catalog because usually when you hear
Marvel Universe yeah you go oh no it's
really just barble earth you know yeah
yeah it's like it's the capes and
superhero superpowers you know yeah all
on earth and it's like this is like
we're not gonna even take place later
this is gonna make it old separate thing
we need out of the way early on yeah and
this is a different kind of movie and I
hope that they keep you know branching
out to the different types of comm oh
they can go crazy like down the road
they could even do like a Planet Hulk
movie if they wanted to yeah and I and I
hope that this makes things better for
you know some of their upcoming projects
cuz you know trouble trouble with
daredevil ant-man hey man Edgar Wright
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] you're a doer of good
get out of your house I just wanted a
stereo but you know I love lino right
[ __ ] you Oliver [ __ ] you sunny bunny
don't ever make it but we're not gonna
there's no comedy anymore this is more
of the kind of review where you could do
like a whole commentary allow you to
pause it and then talk about that five
minute scene for like a half hour
nothing and the post-credits scene yeah
I love the way they tied in with
the second phase of the Avengers yes
brilliant totally all cuz you know our
the tower the duck is gonna be yeah the
new villain yeah is great Howard the
Duck will return just had so much humor
in it as film isn't you how to be funny
what even then like they're poking fun
at the formula yeah exactly
Oh what crazy [ __ ] is coming after the
credit what what tease of the next film
and it's just it's not only is it silly
but it's how are the duck like just like
well done for for poking fun at this
dance put a lot of work into the
technology on him well is well I notice
that it only do yeah they didn't have to
well guys that's our long-ass review so
reason a C's movie is just the movie
it's the movie yeah the reason movies
are made it so it's the it's the movie
that reasons are made for it's the movie
that reasons the word reasons even exist
yeah it's like is to what's what's
ratted the cast
what's rad music what's rad the action
that effects the practical Alec do they
use they used a lot of practical effects
which is really cool for most those
creatures and stuff yeah a [ __ ] played
the raccoon the whole time do they mocap
that because they mode captain okay I
was actually curious no they did all
right well even hey well not Barty's
well it has good well hey you could play
with perspective they did it with Lord
of the Ring that's not true John Riis
maybe psoriasis really that's John
rhys-davies is like 9 feet tall he plays
a three foot tall guy alright guys
thanks for checking out a review for
guardians of the galaxy if you have a
question why don't you ask us or
question no no that's gonna be allowed
to respond to yeah why don't you go
ahead scroll to that comment box below
and tell us who do you like the most out
of guardians of the galaxy then once
you're done with that there's a link
somewhere probably here where you can
check out more reasons to see because
you
want to hear how transformers age of
extinction was and last but not least if
you want to get updated every [ __ ]
time one of our [ __ ] videos are
[ __ ] it I would [ __ ] subscribe
[ __ ] oh that subscribe button Jerry
changes life forever it does nothing is
that nothing will ever be the same I
mean when you subscribe this is the
relaxed portion yeah this is the relaxed
portion this is when the credits are
supposed to be rolling but we don't have
credits it's just the two of us all
right we should be one of those people
who just edit our videos and just have a
bunch of credits just see right right
engineer look right as you go up and
there's like vague soft jazz in the
background uh-huh
pretty much wherever you were sitting do
you come on I didn't come on the couch
I've never come on my couch and I had
like combed while on my couch I've never
come on my couch all right I'm just
gonna stand I'm just gonna stand here